well here's probably the most insane
pitch for a liberal city mayor Eric
Adams trying to sell folks on why New
York City is the greatest place on Earth
because it could be subject to a
terrorist attack like 911 at any
moment New York uh this is a place where
every day you wake up uh you could
experience everything from a plane
crashing into our Trade Center to a a
person who's celebrating a new business
that's open uh this is a very very
complicated City and that's why it's the
greatest City on the globe now you'd
think you would want to clean up those
comments and apologize for the
insensitive 911 comparison but no mayor
Adams was doubling down
today the sentence
police that sit in front of the TV and
say let's wait to see Eric make one
sentence that we can turn into a front
page listen you're gonna find many of
them because I'm authentic and I'm going
to talk the way New Yorkers talk those
who take my comments in good faith are
not going to try to turn them around and
all of a sudden say you are trying to
desecrate the
911 so Dana maybe he made those comments
because he was digging to the bottom to
try to find like good things left about
New York I don't know I I know I I I do
love New York I'm frustrated my biggest
frustration right now is the sanitation
situation there is trash
literally everywhere the trash cans are
not big enough the trash doesn't get
picked up enough that's my big problem I
feel for him in a way
because I'm sure he would love to have a
doover but then I also kind of admire
he's like look I'm just talking give me
a break I'm moving on I'm trying to be
the leader of this city it was a very
poor choice of words I'm sure a hundred
things could run into through his mind
before he should have said that um but
one of the things he might consider
doing is when somebody ask you something
like that if you're not exactly sure
what you want to say you just say it's
interesting that you ask me that and
that gives your brain time to catch up
so that you can say something Harold
knows all about this because I'm sure he
has used this tactic before harol this
is an interesting question the uh I'm
I'm with on this I give people the
benefit of the doubt I don't think
there's a person that loves the city
more than Eric Adams I love the city I
live in this city I'm raising my kids
here uh I might not have chosen that
those words and I think I and trying to
give it the most favorable light maybe
he meant to say also we've recovered
from this this is the greatest City
because of our resilience
I'm like you I I want the crime and the
public safety issues addressed more as
well as sanitation and um I think the
mayor's committed to that so so Jesse
Eric Adams has a 28% approval rating
which is the lowest of any New York
mayor in a quarter century and 72%
disapprove of his handling of the
homeless issue yeah the mayor's shot he
looks like he knows he's about to be
indicted at any second these federal
charges have destroyed him he looks like
a shell of his former self but he
crossed the mob boss Joe Biden anytime
you cross the Boss look what he did to
Mendez look what he's doing to Trump
look what he's doing to Adams he did it
publicly on migration it was a sore
subject for the president and now he's
destroyed his entire political future
and it's sad to watch because the guy
does really care about the
city um he's also
vegan and so he's running on fumes ktie
you know better than anybody at this
table that men
animal protein and you combine that with
the fact that he's burning the candle at
both ends cuz he's doing this restaurant
scene all the time he's waking up he's
tired he's hungry and his approval
ratings in the gutter and now he's
looking at the fact that he's going to
spend the rest of his life paying White
Collar criminal defense attorneys to
fight this Federal indictment that's
about to hit at any second I'd be saying
stupid stuff too but Katie I speak with
Precision because I was trained to speak
with precision and I've never said
anything that's gotten
my true Greg should we get the May some
PE protein I you know it's I think what
Jesse hit on something the science is
settled settled vegan diets do cause
brain damage uh remember they asked the
thing is they asked him for one word and
he said New York that that he should
have just stopped and right there and
just said pass uh and saying a big draw
to the city is Terrorism is kind of in
my opinion counterintuitive this is like
a really handsome guy saying his best
quality is chyia because you know I'm so
appealing that I attract the worst
that's what he's saying it's you can use
this Logic for anything it's like you
know yeah we got a lot of property theft
but that's CU we have so many great
products to steal and yeah our murder
rate's High because this City's
literally to die for and our homeless
problem speaks to our ample awnings and
our wideside walks but I think his point
was that anything could happen here and
so he did a kind of a list argument and
people see the list as everything's
equal when it's not uh but I would have
put that down on the list you know put
put like great shopping dining theater
but then he says you know one of the
things was that like people are opening
up businesses and I see a lot of empty
stores the only stores that are doing
well in New York right now are the pot
stores cuz you got to be high to live
here there are a lot of pot stores I've
noticed more than usual yes hi everyone
I'm Brian kilme I want you to do me I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now